can you remember how we met yeah no I
don't know how you say no always been
around
yeah exactly always been around through
work definitely through work yeah it was
through work then we'd meet out it's
like it became more than just work yeah
whenever kind of weird whenever we're at
parties you enter a room you've got such
a kind of magnetism you do when you
enter a room and they're kind of that
that portal of that Majan we've had so
many kind of fun amazing moments
together and I just me it was always
like that the person could understand
that kind of ethereal magic and kind of
channeling that sort of for which encode
hypnotizing feeling I want this sense I
have I understand that kind of going
that magical emotional portal though
you're in that song will enter it and
shine
that bit at the end when I was kind of
like all of that thing in it and it was
nighttime it was the last shot was like
running on adrenaline and and and Evan
and the music and then everyone kind of
like it was it was the feeling and I the
sensation of like I got that all of that
euphoria that you were talking about
that a moment kind of all come together
at that moment when you explain those
things to me in fact and when you didn't
when Nathan were and you know the whole
that was it was a joint it was a team
today and we got up and we were in the
kind of on the side so dancing with you
that so much fun when they do and you
going sibling is your turn they are the
moments that you loved in the film we
just been with I loved being with all
those dancers and everything I just
loved I knew but you know a lot of them
and yeah so it was all kind of like in
bellos their natural family which is
practically my family well and then over
to slow ride you know and old friends
were there and it was all kind of like
and that song and everyone feeling
really up for it so it was you know they
were all there with you in spirit and
loving it just as much I know I saw line
only it's really that it's so nice to
have that connection with people with us
I was so much I work so much on my own
yeah I'm always on set by myself so to
be able to be with people and to be able
to interact with somebody is it's great
and different so you could talk about it
for hours
I person okay no no no interesting the
base of this was something that I have
met with oils myself for years
so it's kind of the base was always
there and I've always I've always just
have one set every word that's why I
panic adversity study almost about how
you can time travel how you can affect
people through sense so but it is it's
psychoactive it literally it can change
your state of mind if you know that when
you sit over the neuroscientist and they
go you know literally there's two two
steps cake you know of it there's the
limbic system and it's two steps are
actually affecting how you feel with
everything else is like hundreds of step
into the brain the filters where this is
like - I mean but I just do get that but
then I go around she sprays the magic
way naturally it all damn you don't lie
yeah you put it too low you can yeah
it's you really did better for you
and to the dream a fragrance by
Charlotte Tilbury